hello movie-going fans my name is ryan
right welcome reasons to see ramen to
cover the interesting news that i found
interesting in the interesting week of
june wayne the rock johnson is in
negotiations to produce and star in the
remake of Big Trouble in Little China
Dwayne Johnson is especially excited for
this film because big trouble relates to
his awesome size body and Little China
relates to know his asian penis hot
rumor it's rumored that in the new
ant-man film they'll probably reference
spider-man and Oscorp this is just what
we need another Marvel film weren't the
most exciting moments are when they're
promoting another Marvel film it's been
announced that Fox's 24 spin-off will
not feature Jack Bauer sure people will
still want to watch it will be directing
a biopic of Captain Chesley Sully
Sullenberger in case you guys don't know
who he is he became an American Hero
after landing a disabled jet on the
Hudson River and his last name's burger
so might beat you it's rumored that the
second installment of the Star Wars
anthology film will probably be about
Boba Fett and han Solo this will be an
origin tale about Han Solo a Bubba Fett
when they were male lovers who were
homosexual male lovers and then Han Solo
began cheating on Boba Fett with Greedo
these are all facts paramount adds two
new female writers to the transformer
Cinematic Universe after horrible poor
trails of [ __ ] woman in the
Transformers films they now have hired
two real [ __ ] uh I'm kidding I don't
know if they're actually [ __ ] but they
probably are Batman Suicide Squad scene
has been revealed I don't know what it
is because I don't want the [ __ ]
movie ruined for me Justin Lin is in
talks to direct star trek 3 Justin Lin
held three of the seven Fast & Furious
movies films that are heavy on action
light on character this is just what we
need to disappoint Star Trek fans who
want to see character development of
their favorite Star Trek characters
Michael Bay is set to direct an
adaptation of a highly anticipated novel
time salvager the film has a unique
premise but everyone already hates it
because Michael Bay is behind it Ron
Perlman is using his social networks to
try to get fans to demand a Hellboy 3 be
made considering the influence Ron
Perlman has in Hollywood it will most
likely not happen alright guys thanks
for tuning in to the movie news of the
week you can follow the Rio rejects on
facebook instagram and twitter and you
can also catch my videos in Latino
Review com which I hear is Robert
Rodriguez Michael Pena and Antonio
Banderas is favorite site